[Music]
spider-man will be swinging into movie
theaters again next weekend spider-man
homecoming will be the sixth time the
webslinger has gotten his own The
Hollywood feature but if you are
starting to experience blockbuster
fatigue don't fret there are plenty of
acclaimed independent movies coming to a
theater near you that includes the
romantic comedy the big sick featuring
silicon valley's Kumail Nanjiani and Ray
Romano so nine eleven Norman I've always
wanted to have a conversation with about
it with people you've never talked to
people about 9/11 the preview of more
standout indie cinema is Fandango
managing editor Erik Davis
Erik good morning we're still giggling
from that clip of the big sick how
awesome is it it's really really good
you know Kumail Nanjiani stars he wrote
it with Emma levy Gordon it's based on
their real-life relationship Zoe Kazan
Ford plays Emily in the film and you
know it's really about the complexities
of an interracial relationship
specifically parental pressures and also
what happens when someone you're dating
gets really sick the big kind of sick do
you whether that should you whether that
just really great performances stand out
from Ray Romano and Holly Hunter who
play her parents in the film and you
know really great to see a Pakistani
American Muslim in the lead role of a
romantic comedy we never see it we
bemoan the state of romantic comedy yeah
every once in a while we get a great one
this is a great one very hard to make
but it's great when they when they come
that's great or another another film
getting a lot of buzz the beguil'd which
is a remake of a 1971 Clint Eastwood
vehicle but this is made by Sofia
Coppola and it's taken from a female
perspective yes yeah really really cool
film no Sofia Coppola won the best
directing prize for this movie at the
Cannes Film Festival only the second
woman to ever win that prize which
boggles my mind it's a civil war drama
about a group of women and children who
holed up in this schoolhouse in the
south and they stumble upon this Union
soldier whose will do this played by
Colin Farrell they nurse
come back to help and that's when the
fun begins it's a little sexy and
sinister it's definitely beguiling great
standout performances from Kirsten Dunst
and Nicole Kidman in this film who gives
these great icy cold stare down called
Kidman what she does with her eyes this
woman one of the best ever in my opinion
he said sexy and sinister and when I
hear those descriptors I think John Hamm
who is in baby driver a highly
anticipated movie this summer along with
Kevin Spacey Jamie Foxx and Ansel Elgort
tell us about it yes if you're looking
for a lesser-known movie that's got some
um this is one of the best reviewed
movies of the year like 97% French on
Rotten Tomatoes and it's about a getaway
driver named baby played by Ansel Elgort
who when he was a kid he was in a car
accident and he's got this ringing in
his ear and so he drowns out that ring
by playing music and so literally every
scene in this film is driven by its
music director Edgar Wright he cuts the
the scenes to the songs and so it feels
like an action musical in that way but
there are no big song and dance numbers
great cast great soundtrack Jon Hamm who
mentioned Jamie Foxx also in a Kevin
Spacey one of my favorite films of the
year not just the summer of the year
highly recommended out this weekend this
is what you need to see my thinking like
veteran actor Sam Elliott giving a lot
of attention for a film called the hero
is a really good film you know Sam
Elliott plays a aging veteran actor who
had a film many many years ago that was
very successful and now he's sort of
struggling with trying to find a role
when everybody wants to just give him a
Lifetime Achievement you know and I take
one of those incredible I was trying to
reunite with his strange daughter very
soulful film great role for Sam Elliott
proving that more roles for guys like
Sam Elliott should be there and I mean
the mustache yeah more roles for dudes
with a mustache is like that that there
aren't many that have what about ghost
story this is Casey Affleck's film what
do we know about it yeah Casey Affleck
just won best actor for Manchester by
the sea spends many of much of the film
in this sheet with two eyes pokes out
which sounds weird but it makes sense
when you watch the film he plays a ghost
who comes back to haunt the woman that
he left behind then you know what this
is probably our
just film on the list long takes long
scenes there's a scene in this film
where rooney mara sits and eats a
chocolate pie and we watch her for five
minutes
eat that chocolate pie and I think
that's good to see the scene where you
know whether that this film is for you
and moody and meditative if you like
movies like that you will probably love
a go story next up Rigsby bare this is a
film about an adult man kidnapped as a
baby which sounds creepy but it actually
is this offbeat eccentric comedy you
know he's kidnapped as a baby all he has
to go in this remote house in the middle
of nowhere is this show this
entertainment show called Briggs bbear
created by his kidnappers once he's a
man he's out in the real world he sets
out to finish the show and complete it
and shoot the finale it really is a love
letter to sort of artistry and creating
something that you're passionate about
and it really is sweet kyle mooney moon
Saturday Night Live was good job a lot
of popcorn to eat Erik Davis
always good to see you thanks for your
time